you're leaving for july 4th or summer
vacation before school starts your empty
house could become a target for thieves
i spoke with a woman tonight who says
her summerlin home was ransacked while
she was away
pretty startling and it's certainly
frightening they're words many would use
to describe a home burglary the feeling
walking into your bedroom and seeing
your windows open
and broken into this woman who asked us
not to identify her says her house was
broken into while she was on vacation we
have been broken into thousands of
dollars worth of her things were stolen
including jewelry family heirlooms and a
registered gun when it comes to property
burglary a lot of times it's you know
people looking for for opportunity metro
officer larry hadfield says anyone can
become a target so it's important to
take precautions when you head out of
town the best way to prevent burglaries
and crime in your neighborhood is to
have an aware neighborhood ask your
neighbors to keep an eye on your
property make sure your house looks
lived in and maybe invest in some lights
that turn on and off with a timer and
don't post online and advertise that
you're away if these criminals want to
get in and they know that they have a
window of time to do so
apparently that they're willing to do it
this woman says she thought she did
everything right but her family still
got hit so she wants others to know this
can happen to anyone no matter where you
live i don't know where and how to feel
safe now
officer hadfield also said any video
surveillance can be helpful whether from
your home or your neighbors he says your
home does get robbed don't touch any
points of entry or places there could be
fingerprints and wait for police to get